what do you think can be done to stop
this stuff have you thought about it
yeah I think about it all the time it's
it's it's a harder question for me to
ask them to come up with ways of why we
don't need gun control right you know
because that's that's yeah you know it's
hard especially when I'm taking gun
control off the table because people are
always saying you know you guys don't
you guys don't want to move one inch
well it's like yeah because we've been
moving an inch for the last 20 30 so the
problem is it's a it's a [ __ ] up
argument because the people that are
holding the guns are not necessarily the
people that are doing these things
you're trying to attack the the vast
majority of gun owners are not
committing crimes with their guns
they're not so when I think about what
can we do to stop different types of
shooting for instance let's talk let's
start with the let's start with what the
type of shootings that happen the most
Brian gang violence right so if you look
at the statistics you think oh my gosh
America's war zone right 3,000 people
you die in an in the vast majority of it
that is remaining as actual homicides is
gang violence so then we have a gang
problem we have a gang problem in this
country we have a socio-economic problem
in very specific areas in this country
right because I just came from South
Side Chicago where I started in Hyde
Park where Obama used to live and in
drove a few minutes into an area that
look like a bomb went off they don't
have the violence in High Park that they
had in that area why had the same access
to illegal guns they don't have the same
problem because there's a difference in
economics and no one wants to judge when
no one wants to address that right I'm a
kid growing up in that neighborhood and
I'm going to a school that shitty right
I don't give a damn about me I I lucked
up and was able to go to good schools
right I went to schools where my
teachers cared I went to schools where
teachers pushed me when I was slacking
off you know I had the ability to take
out loans to go to a good law school you
know I had those abilities if I'm a kid
growing up in this environment and I
can't find refuge in my school I can't
find refuge at home because my mom's
working three or four or five jobs so
she's never there where am I gonna go
find parents I'm gonna wear
gonna find that pure into influence you
can fight on the streets so now I'm on
the streets being make money what am I
gonna do for money well then there's the
knock economy very conveniently right
there for me right so drugs so now I'm
selling now I'm staying on the corner
selling drugs I gotta protect my product
all right if I don't someone's gonna
take it from me so what do I do I get a
gun I carry a gun now I'm stuck in a
situation I'm just stuck in this violent
loop right there that feeds on itself
and so now I'm stuck defending myself
against the guy who's shooting at me
trying to take my stuff and I'm shooting
back at him maybe not because I'm trying
to take your stuff but because he's
trying to take mine all right
so that's what you get that violence
that comes from that from those
particular areas now if we would have
sat back and said okay we have hyper
concentrated areas in this country this
is a widespread it's hyper concentrated
communities in this country that are
dealing with this that are also the
result of the vast majority of our gun
violence if we sat back and thought
about from a social economic standpoint
how do we fix this what do we do how do
we present opportunity
I'm not saying gonna just hand out stuff
but how do we fix this from the
standpoint of improving our schools
house I can draw five minutes one
direction and have a school that has
everything you can name and then drive
in a drive in the opposite direction and
schools can barely have textbooks to
give to their kids hmm think about that
yeah so why aren't we focusing our
energy on building that up versus
talking about oh we need to get the guns
off the streets you did that you have
that in Chicago you have every gun law
imaginable in Chicago but yes our
Chicago still looks the way that it does
still has a violence that it does right
so if we would if we provide I mean you
give people something lose or to live
for they don't throw away life so easily
plain and simple so it's nice social
economic status is in the dirt I don't
have a problem looking at another kid
down street and shooting at him taking
his life I don't have anything I don't
have anything to lose but if we were to
focus our attention in fixing that same
way we talk about the mental health
issue with respect of Nash Healey's in
school shootings we wouldn't have to
worry about the guns because we won't
have people wanting to do those things
or have the capability to do listening
right so then that deals with that vast
majority of the violence that we had
there focusing that energy in fixing
those communities I agree with you 100%
and we've talked about this many many
times in the show that I think that if
you wanted to make America a better
place one of the best ways to do it is
to make it easier for someone to succeed
make it easy and stop pretending that
it's a level playing field because I
didn't grow up in a level playing field
I got lucky I did you got lucky a lot of
people did and if you go to somewhere
like the south side of Chicago and you
don't realize that you got lucky
you're blind then there's we if you want
to what's the best way to make America
stronger less losers less people who
lose or how is that well give them more
of a chance give them more of an
opportunity and give them guidance ship
community centers clean up the streets
fix buildings but that's a lot of
[ __ ] money that we're spending right
now in Afghanistan and Iraq and even
missiles and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
that we're not putting any money into
that but then who do we hold accountable
we for friendly doing like like if we
talk about the inner cities for instance
mm-hmm they've been democratically run
for ages now the local leadership
there's democratic right but there's no
money there the problem is there's no
money's going somewhere look I mean look
at Chicago it's not enough I mean the
the money is going into the areas where
people are wealthy and that's what
they're supporting they're not
supporting these impoverished areas and
but then and you know what you're
absolutely right so if that's the case
and we all understand that and you know
that stop someone's [ __ ] about gun
control that well let's just say that
that's just one one aspect yeah I agree
with you there so in that sense in when
it comes to gun violence it's very
complex when it comes to gang violence
and it's very complex and I agree with
you that they need there's no other way
to stop that then to fix the inner
cities where people are just in that
cycle of constant poverty and crime and
that's all they see around them so it
becomes normalized yeah